[Music]
whoops
is this seriously still going on how
many weeks has it been do we still need
to
cyber simple memes he got bell to say
his name
without spending a cent
scythe chad sergeant i knew it
i knew it look at those eyes there's so
much
testosterone he's about to bleed through
his eyes i knew it i never been so proud
of my life i can't really move my face i
mean my head
but i am extremely proud just know oh my
god i'm crying
i made a pewdiepie and marching 4 guy
toy
hey that's kind of cool i like it
oh dope hey we got the sip merch
marcia's got the strawberry dress
everyone
the viral dress for some reason felix
you have 69 days to claim these toys oh
my god
i would trust me i would i just don't
like having things
so i would ask you humbly to give it to
one of the 19 year olds
thank you very much very cool just found
out me and pewds have the same fireplace
i don't know what to do with this
information
what's that what do you mean are you
serious
are you are you freaking serious with me
right dude
fire same fireplace broke this right now
right now all right this is very
annoying
i need to i need one more layer hold up
guys
yes yes yes yes yes this is good very
good
what happened to this channel one day
we'll return to the normal
how's it going bros my name is pewdiepie
how about my hair it's stuck in my hair
it's stuck in my hair help me
came here to let felix know oh great
thank you thank you so much
god damn it came into life is know that
his switch isn't docked properly
and having it sit like this can cause
death how how would it cause damage
51 000 upvotes are you kidding me i
spent 2 000
on tambourines and you're only talking
about the switch
are you kidding me clearly it's sitting
way too high up
to even be near the dock is that look it
says
this guys guys mike my phone oh god it's
it's not properly docked guys it's gonna
cause damage
you'll understand i'ma let them go i'm
about to explode
careful i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
i just saw that and i couldn't focus on
anything else in the video
because i have ocd oh really oh it's
bothering you
it's like slight issues is bothering you
oh okay
okay sorry let me just adjust my monitor
yeah that's better
sorry guys i didn't realize you guys
were so sensitive
about uh different issues
so let me adjust the camera as well
that's better right oh sorry guys let me
fix let me fix that for you there you go
that's better right
this place is g field
sorry about that guys i didn't i didn't
realize
let me just fix everything is that
better is that better everyone happy now
sorry i shouldn't be so childish low-key
this this frame kind of fire though
i kind of like it i think i'll keep it
i'm just crazy like that i spent 2 000
on a video hey
i knew my cauliflower was gonna make it
i posted this on instagram
my vegetable had a smile on him before
he died epic
might says of you he's probably texting
other girls
bye-bye somebody had a smile on him this
is awesome
she didn't write this you can tell that
they changed the text but it's very good
see this is funny that deserves 50 000
upvotes
big peepee of course pewte's enjoying
his life
his past sneaks up on him appears oh my
god this [ __ ] god damn it stop it
i will do it all right i will have sex
with markiplier
i just need 107 million subscribers
we're at 106 now
it is actually bothering me a little bit
i'm not gonna lie okay
sorry i wouldn't i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry about that one bro i'm sorry
about it bro
ah perfect watch people complain out
change the camera back
we it tilted change it back change it
back
we want oh what am i doing
i thought it would stick for some reason
i'm not gonna lie guys
i'm kind of pewdiepie in 2050 be like
we did it 49 year olds we hit
500 million
ah profit
tambourine tower is almost at the moon
nasa and i have been working together
for 20 years
in the tambourine moon tower completion
now we could finally brew no gold
there turns out he does have a torso oh
my god i have a torso
okay and it's not a tambourine look
i do look cute though don't i look cute
when felix retires youtube should give
him a pause button oh hey that was sick
i've already retired legit i don't care
i'm just doing youtube for fun at this
point anyway
the more his beard grows the crazier he
gets
no i'm very mature thank you very much i
make philosophical
videos thank you very much mom go play
with the neighbor's kid
the neighbors i am not the neighbor's
kid okay
this is really important that you
understand this i am not the neighbor's
kid
i had to deal with the neighbor's kid
all my life and i will not go through
this slander
on my own subreddit huh all right you
understand me
i will cause damage you don't mess with
me there will be damage
okay i'm doing damage right now it's not
docked properly guys
am i okay yes i am okay stop asking hey
felix
i'm an actual airline pilot oh [ __ ] and
can help you fly
what hell yeah fly the airplanes on
flights
i don't care about flight simulator i
thought he was gonna let me fly that
thing
it is all right how about this
help me fly in flight simulator first
and if you think i do a good job which i
will of course
then you have to let me fly the boeing
747.
i think we have ourself a deal all right
what do you say homie
shake on that one tambourine that
pierces to heaven
holy [ __ ] i love this fanart this is
probably one of my
no yeah yeah i think it is one of my
favorite fan arts
right here huge peepee shout out to
xango art
i need that cape and i need those
glasses and i need that
i need i love it it's perfect it's got
simp in the back
it's got two it's going i'm getting
emotional guys i don't know
tree of life lives on oh my god it looks
like tree of
tambourine tower is tree of life we will
connect him from
the earth to the moon listen nessa call
me
all right for those who don't know we're
trying to build a tambourine tower to
the moon
if you're working on nasa we have pilots
apparently watching
surely someone working on nasa can talk
to me
uh i'll i'm willing to share some of my
secrets and you can share all of yours
and then we can make this thing happen
cause i'm tired of being on this earth
okay
let me get the tambourine tower to the
moon i don't think i'm asking for that
much dear felix i am the original
peepee tower champion okay uh all right
let's count the tambourine and see how
tall he is okay so he's like a meter
tall
as you can see me however i'm like four
meters tall here
uh for americans that's like 15 feet or
something
so i believe you know with all due
respect i respect the effort i respect
the hustle but you ain't no champion all
right
i'm the goddamn champion know your
goddamn place all right
you one meet the tall son of a son
i salute you tambourine knight
okay but i'm the tambourine king
understand
don't ever try to challenge me i'm going
to the moon
you're going like as far as i can i can
jump higher than that
why is he dissing his audience i'm
joking
oh my god it's black james charles holy
[ __ ] meanwhile in a parallel universe
oh my god it's gay pewdiepie holy
what the hell what is this i'm i'm not a
gay
pewdiepie german pewdiepie all right
gay german pewdiepie is real i didn't
know good thing i'd recognize
deutsch hey deaf smiles at us all
all we can do is smile back marcus
cauliflower son rest in peace i salute
you as well
beautiful as uh as a huge peepee and you
know what you get a ppt
i'm sorry i want to crash into that ugly
[ __ ] tower
america america oh
for some reason it didn't click in my
head that that was an appropriate
inappropriate thing to say
god damn it i still stand by it though
it's an ugly ass tower
uh just for the record everything i've
ever said is a joke there
i'm protected now it's tambourine tower
prototype uh of course i own a
stepladder
and then uh another video we had to
borrow this stepladder from our
neighbors
so that god damn it okay we just moved
properly that's why i couldn't fit the
stepladder
as much as it hurt my saw i have a
stepladder i'm a man
filled with the thunderone i'm not a
ship
i'm not forgive me father for i have
sinned
damn it's like a last of us martial kind
of feyenoord
see this is the thing it's like my fan
arts are always amazing but
somehow marx says fan art takes it to
the next level well done
that's a peepee god damn you guys are so
talented
pewds julian i challenge you to make a
better connecticut bro
because you can truth oh no did he he
did it oh god
this is bad this is bad he did not
julian can't even eat bread he's gluten
intolerant i got called out
let's get that look how [ __ ] my
camera quality is oh my god he can help
you
with all the respect he's not ashamed
that guy right either so that does not
make me look good right now don't
compare me to julian
because he cooks well julian i challenge
you to make better connect your breath
yeah i all right yeah all right let's
see let's see it
okay it's a little thick though
but it looks good parchment paper worked
they didn't stick at all popping up
that's kind of what they look like all
right let's see
no mine looks so bad don't show this
don't look at me should we make a little
stack of them a little stack of it
take a bite i've never had crisp bread
it's gonna be like a i think a mix
between lipsticks oh this makes me
hungry they look good
well cheers if you made this along with
me and cheers felix thank you for
showing me a new food
even if it was challenging me and my
skills
it sounds crispy oh oh that's good
yes whoa that is really good
am i swedish now yes i become swedish
he performed the ritual we tricked him
bros
so he's not swedish he is gluten
intolerant but he's still made better
connected brother than me this breaks my
heart but i do respect it
i gotta respect it all right well you
know what
hey julian all right you think you can
insult me
by making better can swedish make your
brother me that's
that what it is well i challenge you
to challenge me all right anything you
can do i can do it better
you know why i just feel like that's the
case
hey shout out to julian big peepee
subscribe to julian
epic august 2069 big pp tambourine tower
reaches the moon
holy all right i take back everything i
said about martial fanart this is better
this is better nasa just call
you have my number we text all the time
answer my calls
who marcia thought she was marrying who
she actually married yeah i glue
up what's the problem all right what do
we got
[Music]
yes yes look at this y'all a bunch of
sims
this subreddit is a bunch of sims i knew
it might look so pretty yeah so
she she drew 20 000 up votes how many do
you think i got
200. it's not fair
this is my subreddit pierce if swedes
comes near me
uh in sub account i would diss you mr
beast who never wanted to take pizza
plays and also help pierce gain subs
during teaser's work
it's all a joke it's all good fun i will
kill you
i'll corrupt the giant i will grow up
the child again
pewdiepie fan art better than mighty fan
art nothing can change my mind that's
god
goddamn beautiful
oh yeah it's short and thick you got a
problem with that
your peepee when you unsubscribe form
pewdiepie yeah
and this works actually yeah this
actually works the way all the way
around
were your peepee when you subscribed to
pewdiepie 20
pp increase subscribe now for 20 larger
penis
again i have pewdiepie fan
yes it's the better that's goddamn
beautiful
i wonder if i can drink from this i
don't have any g fuel next time i'll try
oh my god i told you bros i am 15 meters
tall
i've said this all the time but no one
believes me
[Laughter]
impossible
hey new meme template i like that no
stop how is that possible
how is that possible if this vid gets
500 000 likes i will drop a coke mail in
this track
all right yeah yeah yeah it's done
i have it's recorded i just need to
shoot a video for it but i don't know
i need someone to help me because i i
want it to be good we made a
reddit so post your portfolio if you
filmed anything cool or anything like it
and if you do
your experience with productions uh i
want to work with you
so check out the link in the description
uh
and upvote people stuff that look cool
as well so you can help out find people
that are good
so we made a subreddit for it link in
description check it out
what i remember that pierce is a big fan
of old fletcher
cartoons so i wanted to make an intro
homage to that that's so cool
hell yeah oh my god
yes oh that's an intro
ah that's so cool it's i oh my god
it's five centimeters in size might say
chuckles what's so funny
[Laughter]
i didn't get it until now oh my god
martial you dare define me she will hear
it
we have like a system in the house
monsieur you will pay for this
i will fight any irish person 162
centimeters
italian 27 marzia
same height same year from italy well
well well jack better be running for his
life because he's about to get an air
swooping
i'm so proud of this community maybe i'm
not a ship
that's a cool fan art that's a really
dope fan that deserves an upload
interviewers what do you see yourself
doing in 10 years
here's 10 years ago i don't know yeah
i swear we were normal at one point i
have control of the bridge
piers don't don't do it i control the
bridge see
don't ever challenge me on the bridge in
fallout guys because i'm [ __ ] you
i control all the bridges from now on oh
my god that's so
cute damn that [ __ ] looks good she's
floor gang because she barely even walks
oh that's adorable this is so
an eerie yes
this is my parents in anime style
[Applause]
wow holy [ __ ] that's the biggest ppo of
them all
oh my god it looks just like my parents
this is so weird
i'm cringing and i'm amazed at the same
time this is such a weird emotion you
need
92 billion tambourines to reach the moon
which means you need to spend around uh
all right guys donate on the live
streams it all goes to tambourines
mr beast reaches 70 million beauty
i won't do it obviously i won't do that
don't ever come near me mr bees i will
not want to do it
guys i just realized i haven't said this
before uh but we're selling tambourines
right
you can actually wear them at shoes as
well on your feet they work surprisingly
well
and you can slide them quick i mean i
don't
have and this video is over now
thank you for watching guys smash like
if you enjoyed subscribe
and i'll see you guys next time harder
so yeah so seriously
ah children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures far spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo's switch
and remember it has a very big tv
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]
we